[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 on se
retrouve ce soir pour une nouvelle
édition du best of des meilleurs moments
du 7 8 on s'intéresse ce soir au mois de
décembre un mois qui a été marqué par
deux grandes causes comme la Journée
mondiale contre le sida le premier
décembre ou encore l'opération 2022 du
Téléthon mais également des actualités
marquantes on revient sur ces moments
[Musique]
on en parlait il y a quelques instants
le premier décembre c'est la journée
mondiale de lutte contre le sida au
niveau national des dépistages sont au
ralenti j'y revendrai je le rappelle
vous êtes le directeur général de HF
prévention santé c'est le cas également
dans les Yvelines les dépistages sont au
ralenti on le voit il y a eu une
démobilisation déjà des structures qui
pouvaient potentiellement faire du
dépistage les centres de dépistage
anonymé gratuit donc ce qu'on appelle
donc les cejid qui à terme deviendront
probablement d'ailleurs des centres de
santé sexuelle ont été réacées aussi
pour faire de la vaccination covid
notamment on a eu ensuite une autre
pandémie qui est apparue durant l'été et
qui a été très vite maîtrisé qui est
donc la variole du singe le manque
époque donc on en avait déjà aussi parlé
et ça a aussi mobilisé les mêmes acteurs
donc du du milieu affectieux tout ça
combiné fait que effectivement la lutte
contre le sida fait partie des Pat qui
ont souffert parce que du coup moins de
dépistage et donc une prise de
conscience bien moindre malgré donc les
efforts HF prévention on continue
notamment donc dans les Yvelines et on
fait partie des rares structures qui
continuent donc à faire du dépistage
nous je vous rappelle on est opérateur
donc pour le ministère de la santé mais
infini on le voit que ce soit en
Île-de-France ou que ce soit
particulièrement dans les Yvelines il
est encore difficile de pouvoir
reconquérir effectivement des
territoires et de pouvoir aller donc
dépister les gens d'une manière simple
tout cela engendre effectivement un très
grave retard au dépistage parce que les
gens qui sont effectivement non
découverts peuvent potentiellement donc
déclencher des cas de sida et donc
décéder et puis faire des formes de
cancer ou autre puisque du coup ça fait
partie effectivement des différentes
pathologies et en plus continuent à
contaminer d'autres personnes sans le
savoir donc on va avoir effectivement
dans les années à venir un boom de de
contamination et heureusement
effectivement que les pouvoirs publics
continuent à se mobiliser et notamment
aussi les les structures type la région
Île-de-France autour de Valérie Pécresse
qui donc permet aussi d'avoir des hôtels
des tests
comment se faire dépister donc on peut
aujourd'hui donc se faire dépister dans
les unités mobiles d'achève prévention
que ce soit à 50 ans en Yvelines on
travaille beaucoup avec l'Université de
50 ans en Yvelines parce qu'on me
rappelle les quatre contaminations c'est
essentiellement les personnes qui sont
moins de 25 ans parce que effectivement
ils n'ont pas encore ce réflexe de
pouvoir utiliser donc le préservatif et
puis les plus de 45 ans alors santé
publique France dit les plus de 50 ans
mais en réalité la charnière c'est les
plus de 45 ans parce que il peut y avoir
des changements de vie et puis des
nouveaux comportements quand vous avez
été en couple pendant 20-25 ans et que
vous
retrouver une forme un peu différente de
sexualité bien vous allez prendre des
des risques parce que vous vous sentez
pas forcément concerné parce qu'on
imagine toujours que ça peut être les
autres actualités de ce weekend c'était
également le Téléthon plus de 78
millions d'euros ont été recueillis
vendredi et samedi en France contre les
maladies et génétiques rares alors quel
est le bilan dans les Yvelines ou
plusieurs animations étaient également
organisées pour récolter des fonds
exemple à Magny-les-Hameaux et aussi
dans la commune des Clayes-sous-Bois
avec Mathilde Franco et Nicolas dandry
l'Alsace à l'honneur au gymnase Chantal
Mauduit de Magny-les-Hameaux pour cette
36e édition du Téléthon et cette année
la commune a été choisie pour être le
village du secteur est dans les Yvelines
une fierté pour l'association objective
Téléthon manicois qui existe depuis 15
ans
nous étions à 3,83 € par habitant c'est
un beau chiffre parce qu'on est un euro
13 à Paris on en est très très fier
cette fierté fait que nous sommes
aujourd'hui
village Téléthon reconnu donc dans ce
qui est fait ici à magny-les-maux au
programme de nombreuses animations
basket coloriage et course sportive
aujourd'hui on a fait un une course
itinérante avec plus de 30 jeunes
sapeurs-pompiers on en a parlé en début
de semaine c'était lundi que débuter le
procès du Val Fourré de Mantes-la-Jolie
au tribunal judiciaire deux Versailles
le procès se termine aujourd'hui on
connaît maintenant les réquisitions
alors effectivement pour rappel le
procès se tenait pour dénoncer un
système de raquettes présumée sur le
marché du Val Fourré lui prévenu était
jugé cette semaine après deux heures de
prise de parole la magistrate Pamela
tabardell a réclamé aujourd'hui des
peines variant de 18 mois à 5 ans de
prison ferme sans mandats de dépôt pour
7 des 8 prévenus elle a également requis
une interdiction définitive d'exercer
dans la fonction publique ou de se
rendre à Mantes-la-Jolie pendant 5 ans
pour plusieurs prévenus concernant Sidi
elle Emer excellu Mr intérim de
Mantes-la-Jolie le parquet a demandé une
année de prison avec sursis et une
énigibilité pendant 5 ans l'information
de ce week-end on vous en parlait dans
les titres c'est cette marche blanche
organisée hier dimanche entre Coignières
et Maurepas un moment de paix pour
rendre hommage à Djibril ce jeune
adolescent de 14 ans a été assassiné
lors d'une rixe dans la nuit du 26 au 27
novembre dernier devant le gymnase du
moulin à vent à Coignières on garde le
reportage de Michaël et midoro et de
Nicolas dandry vous vivez les mêmes
galères
les mêmes choses le quotidien il est pas
facile émotion incompréhension et
prévention la maman de Djibril a tenu à
s'adresser aux jeunes qu'il soit de mort
pas de Coignières ou encore de la
verrière ils sont tous touchés par la
disparition de son fils de 14 ans
assassiné il y a 2 semaines il a grandi
ici son père il a grandi à Élancourt son
grand-père il habite à la verrière et il
a des cousins à Trappes donc il a des
copains partout partout la des copains
de Djibril et il a pas il avait pas de
problème
particulière avec les autres pour rendre
hommage à son enfant une marche blanche
a été organisée au départ du gymnase du
moulin à vent à Coignières jusqu'au
stade du bois à Maurepas plus de 1000
personnes ont participé à ce moment de
recueillement mais je le connaissais
ouais on se voyait tous les jours je
vais donner des conseils je lui crier
dessus voilà je suis ami avec son père
le jeune je le connais pas
personnellement mais j'ai beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont amies avec lui qui sont
danseurs avec moi donner un soutien à la
famille parce que ce qui s'est passé
franchement c'est une admissible un
jeune de 14 ans qui est décédé
franchement
c'est une magie noble une atmosphère
silencieuse calme et apaisée entourée ce
rendez-vous en présence des mers des
deux communes liées par ce drame mais il
suffit pas de dire plus jamais ça pour
que ça n'arrive plus il faut
effectivement mettre en place les
mesures qui s'imposent et il faut
effectivement que l'éducation je l'ai
dit dans mon discours il faut que
l'éducation redevienne véritablement la
priorité des priorités parce que ce
n'est que parler d'éducation que nous en
sortirons c'est pas par la répression on
le sait très bien pour rappel
l'adolescent a été tué lors d'une rixe
dans la nuit du 26 au 27 novembre devant
le gymnase du moulin à vent en marge
d'un événement de MMA
d'une le centre hospitalier de
Versailles était victime d'une
cyberattaque victime d'une cyberattaque
samedi soir l'hôpital André Mignot de
Versailles a déclenché son plan blanc
qui permet de prendre des mesures
exceptionnelles en cas de crise vers 21h
des ordinateurs affichés un message
concernant des informations dérobées
pour limiter la propagation sur le
réseau la direction à couper l'ensemble
du système d'information une cellule de
crise a également été ouverte on écoute
le témoignage du maire du chêné
Rocancourt au micro de Patrick Jacques
de Dixmude l'idée c'est d'accompagner
l'équipe qui est en gestion de crise le
temps qu'il faudra donc sans doute
jusqu'à Noël pour s'assurer qu'ils ont
l'ensemble des moyens donc des hier le
ministre de la Santé François Bron est
venu indiqué que le Samus zonal donc le
SAMU de France était venu apporter des
hier soir des moyens notamment en
matière de biologie pour revenir pallier
les les défaillances liées à l'attaque
donc on a en termes matériel on n'aura
pas trop de soucis je pense que la
solidarité va fonctionner derrière il
faut qu'on s'assure que les personnels
tiennent dans la durée
l'ARS Île-de-France Agence Régionale de
Santé invite les patients à composer
directement le 15 en cas d'urgence
l'établissement peut aussi compter sur
la solidarité régionale certains
patients ont été transférés dans
d'autres établissements franciliens
comme il l'explique Alexandre moquedet
directeur de la communication au centre
hospitalier de Versailles
par précaution sur des patients qui
étaient particulièrement instables étant
donné que le système d'information était
indisponible pour faire le suivi et la
surveillance de ces patients au central
qui n'étaient pas possible on a préféré
les transférer
[Musique]
le mois de décembre a également été
marqué par de belles initiatives nous
avions notamment suivi ces sessions de
Job Dating en faisant du tennis ou
encore l'association tiékart qui vient
en aide aux jeunes de banlieue à travers
le théâtre
[Musique]
et avec vous on va parler de théâtre
par l'association de Shaka c'était il y
a quelques semaines au centre culturel
le Chaplin à Mantes-la-Jolie justement
Mamadou Traoré et Marouane harbouch vous
nous avez rejoint bonsoir à vous deux
vous faites partie des mentors de
l'association je vous propose de
regarder le sujet c'est bien super
[Musique]
continue
apprendre à interpréter un rôle tenir la
pause face au public s'écouter et
écouter les autres
laisse un peu les autres derniers aussi
important de laisser la place aussi aux
autres deux fois par semaine ils sont
une quinzaine de collégiens à participer
aux ateliers du dispositif culturel tia
carte mis en place par l'association
Jeunesse sans frontières
soutenu par les établissements scolaires
partenaires le but est d'encadrer la
jeunesse et leur faire découvrir le
théâtre comme moyen d'expression pour
aborder les problématiques sociales
liées à la banlieue il y a un rôle
important celui de mentor justement
comment vous êtes arrivé dans cette
initiative qu'est-ce qui vous a plu et
pourquoi vous êtes joint dans ce
dispositif Marouane alors le mentorat
c'était c'était un projet parmi le grand
projet ikigai donc on a accepté dès
qu'on nous a proposé en fait ce projet
surtout quand on a su que c'était sur le
thème de l'harcèlement c'est un thème
qui touche beaucoup d'enfants
aujourd'hui donc c'est un sujet qui nous
a qui nous a tout de suite touchés donc
on a accepté de de rejoindre le projet
et de de m’entourer ces jeunes 6e des
accompagner d'un point de vue culturel
avec l'association et Mamadou Rudy
utilisait le mot de bienveillance aussi
ce que vous avez ressenti vous dans ce
travail dans ce travail qui est mené
encore actuellement exactement
le travail qu'on a mené on voulait
justement leur retranscrire nous
toutes les bonnes volontés et pour que
ça leur fasse j'ai envie de dire un
bagage un bon bagage pour la vie et
franchement si on peut aider on aide et
culturel franchement c'est un bon moyen
Gabriel alors apportez beaucoup on l'a
compris mais qu'est-ce que eux vous
apportent
franchement ce qui nous apporte un
descriptible j'ai envie de vous dire
parce que c'est des enfants et quand on
parle d'enfant on parle de sujets
sensibles forcément
mais pas que ça nous donne le sourire
franchement de les voir se développer de
ce de se dépasser pour quelque chose qui
leur tienne à coeur aussi parce que
s'ils sont là aujourd'hui
parce qu'ils ont conscience aussi donc
ils veulent faire comprendre à leurs
camarades leur engagement et
la thématique sur laquelle on travaille
dans le cadre de la Semaine des lycées
professionnels le Centre national de
football de Clairefontaine donnait hier
ce mardi 6 décembre plusieurs tableaux
rondes le but faire connaître des
métiers méconnus en lien avec le sport
le reportage du régime ralech ce mardi 6
décembre collégiens lycéen et enseignant
se sont réunis à Clairefontaine dans le
centre national de football le but
découvrir et valoriser les métiers de la
filière professionnelle en lien avec le
sport alors aujourd'hui les élèves
lycéens il y a une douzaine de lycées
représentés avec donc 12 formations sur
la sécurité sur l'accueil de la
maintenance sur de la cybersécurité sur
de la vente et en fait c'est de montrer
qu'il y a des métiers en lien avec le
sport qui sont un petit peu cachés et
qui contribuent mais à la réussite
peut-être des Bleus aujourd'hui pour
donner envie ce des lycéens de filières
professionnelles qui mènent les ateliers
de découverte ici ce sont les métiers de
la sécurité qui sont expliqués gendarmes
policier ou bodyguard pour les
célébrités comme les joueurs de football
de quoi séduire les élèves ça nous ouvre
plusieurs portes et ça nous change de la
générale
pour quelques personnes qui veulent qui
savent pas ce qu'ils veulent faire plus
tard la filière professionnelle pour moi
elle est hyper intéressante parce que on
peut accéder à plusieurs plusieurs
formations ou plusieurs débouchés donc
dans plusieurs métiers tout d'abord
j'aimerais faire un petit tour de table
est-ce que l'un d'entre vous pourrait
m'expliquer ce qu'est un tribunal
administratif alors je pense que comme
son nom l'indique il règle des litiges
liées à l'administration avec des
administrations oui vous avez d'autres
idées
dans le juridique
écoutez alors voici une définition très
claire qui s'affiche à l'écran donc le
tribunal administratif juge les litiges
entre les particuliers et les
administration donc par administration
on entend état collectivités
territoriale établissement public ou
organisme privé chargé d'une mission de
service public
alors cette semaine la semaine de stage
était organisée par le tribunal
administratif et l'académie de
Versailles dans le cadre du parcours
citoyen ce qui permet aux élèves des
collèges des Yvelines classées REP donc
réseau éducation prioritaire
alors excusez-moi
découvrir des métiers de la juridiction
administrative et même de susciter des
vocations donc durant cette semaine les
élèves ont pu assister à des audiences
de chambre de référé et d'urgence
étrangers on écoute tout de suite Amina
l'une des stagiaires au micro de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude je pensais pas que ça
allait être aussi bien
ça a vraiment stage parce que en fait
j'apprends des choses et en même temps
je pensais que ça allait être stressant
et très carré mais en fait pas du tout
on rigole on travaille on travaille on
s'amusant et
ça nous améliore quoi on continue cette
édition avec un très beau résultat vous
en disait quelques mots au début du 7-8
c'est du tumbling il est licencié aux
Clayes-sous-Bois et Axel Duriez vient de
remporter la médaille de bronze au
mondiaux de Tumbling c'était ta Sofia en
Bulgarie nous avons la chance de l'avoir
en compagnie je le disais de son coach
qui est infidèle du plateau on a le
plaisir de le recevoir souvent René et
Bamy qu'est-ce que ça vous fait d'avoir
cette médaille de bronze vous êtes venus
avec d'ailleurs autour du cou ça vous
fait quoi Excel bah ça fait un très
grand honneur déjà puisque c'est
toujours un rêve de gagner face au plus
grand ou même de faire une médaille face
au plus grand aujourd'hui j'ai pu faire
cette médaille batte certains grands que
j'ai toujours rêvé de battre
je suis donc pour moi c'est un rêve
oui j'ai réalisé oui parce que
à chaque fois que je fais une
compétition assez importante dès que le
résultat est tombé je passe déjà à la
prochaine je pense déjà au prochain
compétition qui arrive donc réaliser oui
j'ai dû à réaliser mais je suis déjà sur
mes prochains objectifs c'est pas un
aboutissement pour vous c'est peut-être
la suite d'autres choses mais vous
l'avez fêté quand même cette médaille
rassurée
j'ai fait un peu la fête avec tout le
monde toute l'équipe de France toutes
les personnes qui étaient là et puis en
rentrant chez moi j'ai vu ma famille et
tout le monde m'a félicité il a fait le
buzz récemment avec son nouveau titre
Coupe du Monde au Qatar qui totalise
plus de 100 000 vues sur Youtube le
rappeur curta vient de sortir son
nouveau projet musical 7k82 la suite de
son ep7 K8 sortie il y a deux ans on y
retrouve 10 titres dont Coupe du Monde
au Qatar ou encore Omar Sy avec 800
inédits également kurta parle de son EP
à Grégory canalet on écoute un extrait
c'est des morceaux que sur lesquels j'ai
vraiment beaucoup travaillé et qui sont
à tous il y a de la pop il y a du rap il
y a des messages il y a de quoi s'évader
c'est vraiment un projet qui est je
l'espère va vous plaire qui était le
cocon j'ai dit comme une envie de voir
autre chose comme un goût de
métamorphose fini le maquillage sur le
coton faut quitter quitter le cocon
comme le papy
papy comme le papillon
[Musique]
tout comme le papillon
comme le café l'actualité de ce week-end
niveau sport c'était ses quarts de
finale de la Coupe du monde de football
avec la France avec la France qui a
brillé qui a gagné deux buts face à
l'Angleterre on l'a tous eu je crois 18
millions de Français ont vu ce match à
la télévision et il y a eu aussi la
victoire du Maroc un peu plus
surprenante la victoire du Maroc en tout
cas on a pu suivre ces deux exploits
dans les Yvelines et forcément il y a eu
beaucoup d'ambiance un reportage
1 0 ce sera le score à la pose on a
maîtrisé le ballon bon les Anglais ont
été un peu dangereux mais on a réussi à
marquer tôt donc on est plutôt pas mal
pour la deuxième mi-temps
après ce qui compte c'est de travailler
en équipe et je crois qu'on a su mettre
l'intensité qu'il fallait dans les duels
pour pouvoir se projeter vers l'avant et
marquer le but qui nous faut pour la
victoire refroidi par légalisation
anglaise en début de seconde période les
supporters français continuent d'y
croire et la libération arrivera la 78e
minute grâce à un but de Giroud après
quelques frayeurs les Français sont en
demi-finale de la 22e Coupe du Monde
quelques heures plus tôt ce sont les
supporters marocains qui ont exulté dans
ce bar portugais situé près de la mairie
de Trappes le Maroc s'impose face au
Portugal sur le score de 1 à 0 direction
les demi-finales une première pour un
club africain
la France c'est inclinée hier face à
l'Argentine a égalité trois partout à la
fin du match c'est au tir au but que les
Argentins portés par Lionel Messi se
sont imposés aussi entre joie et
tristesse les supporters Yves Linois ont
suivi ce match d'exception qui n'a cessé
de jouer avec nos émotions jouer au
tennis avec son recruteur juste avant
son entretien d'embauche un concept
original vécu par ses 30 jeunes ici de
quartiers prioritaires lors du jeu 7 et
job ce mardi 6 décembre organisé pour la
première fois attrape par l'association
faite le mur de Yannick Noah cet
événement a permis de rassembler une
dizaine d'entreprises c'est un concept
de Job Dating en fait directement sur le
tennis afin de désacraliser le
recrutement de déstresser un peu les
jeunes ça crée un lien direct qui est
plus facile ou directement le recruteur
et le jeûne se parle sur le terrain on
parlait de salaire de de comment ça se
passe au niveau du travail s'il y a des
jours de repos à particulier
je trouve que c'est une méthode très
innovante qui permet aussi de briser la
glace auprès donc de ces candidats
aujourd'hui il faut aller au devant des
candidats il faut aller les chercher au
plus près de chez eux donc je pense que
le sport aussi permet de mieux prendre
contact avec eux et puis voilà de
faciliter la communication après un
moment sportif l'ambiance est devenue
plus formelle dans ce cadre atypique
table posée à même le terrain pour le
job dating des postes autour des métiers
de la climatisation de la mécanique ou
encore de l'armée était proposée pour
moi c'est super important de participer
au job dating parce que je suis à la
recherche d'un emploi je veux un CDI
soit en restauration en commerce en
garde d'enfant ça permet aussi de se
faire connaître auprès des jeunes
puisque moi je travaille pour une agence
d'intérim et on se rend compte que les
jeunes connaissent de moins en moins le
monde de l'intérim donc c'est vrai que
c'est important aussi de se faire
connaitre quelques barrières en fait des
deux côtés ça lève des barrières
peut-être un peu désappréhension de la
part du jeûne déjà du gène envers le
recruteur c'est peut-être des fois un
monde qui est pas forcément atteignable
mais aussi de la part du recruteur
envers le jeûne qui a peut-être pas la
bonne image des jeunes de quartier en
amont certains de ces demandeurs
d'emploi étaient formés à la prise de
parole en public à travers des
simulations d'autres tiens et des
perfectionnements à l'oral présente dans
toute la France l'association faite le
mur intervient chaque année auprès de
13000 bénéficiaires
au château de Versailles spectaculaire
opération de grutage s'est déroulé ce
mardi matin l'objectif restaurer le
fameux bassin du char d'Apollon situé
dans les jardins dans la continuité du
château l'ensemble a été retiré pour
être acheminé dans un atelier les 13
cultures en plomb seront entièrement
restaurés redorés au total le projet va
nécessiter 18 mois de chantier n'écoute
Catherine péga la présidente du château
de Versailles c'est d'abord une immense
émotion pour nous tous ce matin parce
qu'on a le sentiment de vivre un moment
totalement inédit presque historique si
on n'avait pas peur des grands mots en
assistant à cette ce départ d'Apollon
pour cette grande restauration que l'on
attendait depuis longtemps c'est une
restauration qui a été urgente comme on
a pu vous vous le montrer et comme on
peut le voir on voit de près que ces
sculptures sont extrêmement abîmées mais
que aussi tout ce bassin a besoin d'une
d'une grande restauration et on reste
dans une ambiance hivernale partir au
sport d'hiver dans les Yvelines c'est
possible c'est ce que vous propose de le
parc alpin à côté 2100 installé dans le
premier depuis le 1er novembre sur l'île
des Impressionnistes de Chatou il vous
propose de multiples activités ludiques
qui luge ou encore raclette en
téléphérique Céline Charles vous avez
testé plusieurs activités j'ai testé la
patinoire la luge tant bien que mal le
ski et bien sûr le repas bien dans une
télécabines c'est ça je vous propose de
découvrir ces activités ensemble
[Musique]
faire du ski à quelques minutes de Paris
c'est possible sur l'île des
Impressionnistes de Chatou je me trouve
actuellement au parc alpin à côté 2100
ce qui raclette ou encore patinoire
venait découvrir avec moi ses nombreux
activités
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement avec Céline
Caillat directrice de la communication
et marketing de ce superbe endroit alpin
du coup village alpin qu'est ce que
c'est un petit peu ce que vous pouvez me
présenter du coup qu'est-ce qu'on y
trouve la première station d'hiver de
l'Ouest parisien on y trouve trois sites
dans un site on a une piste de luge une
piste de ski avec biathlon une piste de
ski alpin et une grande patinoire de 500
mètres carrés le parc afterwork avec
trois bars et des DJ à partir de 17
heures le soir et la troisième partie
qui est le domaine de la restauration
avec 150 télécabines et plus de 10
téléphériques qui vont de 8 à 16
personnes donc 11 heures le matin à
23h30
on peut venir déjeuner à partir de 11
heures le matin et toute la journée
c'est un service continu en télécabine
et le soir à partir de 19h en télécabine
pour fondue et raclette c'est vraiment
l'ambiance du ski avec les produits
savoyard un grand sourcing savoyard tous
les produits viennent de savoir et c'est
pour tout public et c'est pour tout
public loin des tout-petits c'est
gratuit pour les moins de 5 ans et on
fait un droit d'entrée mais qu'on
appelle le Pass entrée de 10 euros mais
qui a un bon de consommation c'est pas
une vraie entrée c'est vraiment pour
consommer sur place pour avoir droit à
une attraction à des crêpes et chocolat
chaud et du coup pour la patinoire pour
la consommation d'énergie aussi des
télécabines comment vous avez un petit
peu aménagé ça fait 500 mètres carrés
oui de patinoire un travail avec une
très belle société qui s'appelle
cinerglass où la consommation d'énergie
équivaut à trois foyers de 4 personnes
sur un mois et surtout en tel cabine on
a retiré tous les chauffages qui étaient
présents dans les télécabines les 150
télécabines n'ont pas de chauffage c'est
pour ça qu'on demande nos clients de
jouer le jeu de venir en tenue de ski et
puis on fournit les plaids tous les
jours et le vin chaud moi ça m'a donné
envie en tout cas je ne sais pas où mais
moi tu vas les tester cette activité
bonjour est-ce que ce serait possible de
faire du patin s'il vous plaît
c'est parti
[Musique]
après la patinoire un petit passage par
la piste de luge de plus de 4 m de haut
et 25 mètres de long
puis je me suis rendu sur la piste de
ski un tapis roulant en revêtement
synthétique qui permet de s'initier ou
de retrouver des sensations
après l'effort le réconfort en
télécabine avec une carte savoyarde
appétissante ce sera fondu à la truffe
pour cette fois-ci
si vous n'avez pas la chance de partir
au sport d'hiver à la montagne pas de
panique vous pouvez venir vous initier
ou pratiquer ici jusqu'au 29 janvier
prochain
et un plateau on retrouve aussi Nicolas
dandrie qui arrive également sur son 31
mais on a la même couleur de nœud
papillon de papillon on est un peu sur
les mêmes tons bleus voilà c'est
également avec le petit nœud papillon
rouge ouais également alors Tyson est en
train de monter sur la table voilà on
est on est en direct mais Tyson peut
monter sur la table si s'il le souhaite
il y a pas de souci il y a aussi et bien
les personnes qui contribuent à cette
émission en coulisse les techniciens et
également notre chef d'édition Mélanie
poker m'envoyer la régie de TV 78 avec
Ludovic avec Xavier et avec Nathan qui
sont installés et Mélanie également
derrière qui veille au grain pour que
toute cette émission se déroule de la
meilleure des manières on l'a vu dans
cette émission on vous a donné des idées
de décoration pour le sapin des idées de
cadeaux mais alors je pense que les
Yvelines cherchent aussi à savoir ce
qu'ils vont mettre sur leur table leur
du réveillon et justement à ce propos je
suis allée à la cabane de Grimm pour
filmer la préparation d'une bûche de
Noël je ne sais pas si vous êtes plutôt
sucrés ou salé autour du plateau
sucré
voilà à Noël c'est toujours le petit
mais classique à mettre sur la table et
ben pour les pour les gourmands qui sont
plutôt sucrés je vous propose de
regarder la bûche de Noël concoctée par
la cabane de Grimm à Houdan
bonjour
Cécile François Gomes je suis dirigeante
de la cabane de Grimm et artisan
chocolatier glacier que je vous propose
là c'est de vous présenter le montage
d'une bûche phare que l'on a cette année
qui est la bûche Galaxy puisque toutes
nos pièces tournent autour du thème un
Noël dans l'espace cette année
à vous propose de monter cette bûche on
va commencer par turbiner le sorbet
ananas j'ai déjà préparé à l'avance un
insert sorbet mangue passion que je vais
recouvrir de chocolat c'est parti on va
mixer émulsionner la glace avant de la
mettre en turbine voilà ça permet de
bien lier les éléments entre eux pour
avoir une glace la plus onctueuse
possible et on va verser ça dans la
turbine
[Musique]
voilà et on en a là pour une petite
vingtaine de minutes
[Musique]
alors là maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est
préparer le l'enrobage de notre bûche
[Musique]
alors là on va sortir la glace de la
turbine
[Musique]
je récupère mon insert
faites le montage d'une bûche se fait à
l'envers
[Musique]
alors là nous allons démouler notre
bûche maintenant qu'elle a bien refroidi
[Musique]
voilà je nous avons réalisé ensemble la
bûche Galaxy je vous souhaite de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année
[Musique]
moi je coupe l'orange en petite tranche
je vous ai préparé à l'avance
voilà pas trop épaisse un demi
centimètre c'est parfait
je coupe mes tranches
je prends du fil et une aiguille bon
j'ai choisi un beau jaune la même
couleur que l'orange et puis je peux
faire ça avec plein d'agrumes du citron
jaune du citron vert même du
pamplemousse si je veux
j'enfile mon fil hein et je construis
des guirlandes comme ça voilà que je
vais accrocher sur la fenêtre ou sur la
porte qui peut être autour de la de la
couronne de Noël il nous a été abandonné
au refuge par ses anciens maîtres après
il a été adopté deux fois et
malheureusement il n'arrive pas à
s'habituer à la vie urbaine notamment
avec les enfants on pense qu'il a déjà
été embêté par des enfants et du coup il
les supporte absolument pu donc
maintenant son prochain placement ça va
être dans une maison à la campagne voilà
sans enfant et il s'entend très bien
avec les autres chiens par contre ça
fait combien de temps que que vous
l'avez dans votre refuge du coup on l'a
depuis février donc il va on a une break
il ne fait pas c'est un an au refuge
pas forcément avec des enfants mais en
tout cas il est très câlin c'est ce
qu'on a remarqué aussi en rédaction il
est venu il est venu vers nous avant
l'émission et et voilà là ils vont il
est il montait sur la table mais ouais
ouais c'est quelqu'un c'est c'est un
animal très affectueux ouais très
affectueux très attachant qui protégera
sa famille donc il faut évidemment pas
trop recevoir parce que il est pas fan
des invités au foyer il est gardien
franchement c'est ça qui fait coin
coincé
on tire dessus
alors Tyson il parle bien son nom
[Musique]
je crois que vous avez testé après donc
tout à l'heure vous voyez la bûche vous
avez testé aussi à fabrication du pain
d'épice oui tout à fait avec Gabriel on
est allé faire des décorations sur des
pains d'épices alors c'était pas si
facile que ça Grégory on a eu un peu de
mal quand même donc c'est la décoration
la décoration décoration et puis
assemblage bah je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder le reportage
[Musique]
et je me trouve justement avec Aurélie
sulpizio pour confectionner mon propre
pain d'épices alors Aurélie on commence
par quoi alors nous on a fait les
maisons au préalable avant votre arrivée
donc une pâte à pain d'épices ou dans un
batteur on va mélanger la farine la
levure les œufs et un mélange d'épices
avec de la cannelle de la misère de la
badiane et d'autres que je ne citerai
pas pour des raisons et là on va
s'attaquer aux décorations des petites
maisons super bah je vais essayer de pas
faire n'importe quoi vous allez me
conseiller facile
vous avez déjà tenu une poche à douille
[Musique]
on a fait des couleurs c'est de la glace
royale ça s'appelle c'est un mélange de
blanc d'oeuf de sucre glace avec un
zeste de citron auquel on ajoute du
colorant naturel
[Musique]
vous avez mis deux secondes pour faire
les deux
pour faire ma première fois c'est normal
[Musique]
c'est pas mal
ça fait un peu pain d'épice d'enfants
quand même je pense que la première fois
que j'en ai fait je devais être pire que
vous
et on va voir également Thomas Fletcher
qui était à la caméra volante voilà qui
nous a permis également de pouvoir
d'ailleurs
il a fait son petit pull de Noël
personnalisé TV 78 peut-être que Thomas
vous donnera tous ces bons conseils pour
le réaliser chez vous et cette émission
best of est déjà terminée merci d'avoir
été avec nous sur TV 78 on vous souhaite
de très belles fêtes de fin d'année et
on vous retrouve très vite
[Musique]